greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
February 18th [ __ ] Presidents
Day the podcast is brought to you by
Robin Hood Robin Hood is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options and kryptos or commissions
wait
plus there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get started so you can start
investing at any level with Robin Hood
you can learn how to invest in the
market as you build your portfolio
discover new stocks track your favorite
companies and get custom notifications
for price movements so you never miss
the right move more moment to invest
Robin Hood is giving the church family a
free stock like Apple for the sprint to
help you build your portfolio that's
what we're doing today Tuesday the 19
sign up at church dot Robin Hood calm
again church dot Robin Hood dot-com I
also want to thank on it listen when it
comes to supplements there's no one
better from the Alpha brain to the
shroom tech to the shroom tech immune to
the shroom tech sport I've already been
on them this weekend with the two
[ __ ] planes and guess what I'll be on
them next week with the [ __ ] flying
cuz you never know what type of germs
you're gonna get on a [ __ ] plane
these days anyway go to on impress in
church bad but get 10% off delivered
right to your [ __ ] crib take
this [ __ ] muley Tuesday February
19th by the time you get this hope you
had a great [ __ ] weekend Tom roads in
the [ __ ] house Joey Christ
killers in the [ __ ] house and
his fall isn't the [ __ ] house
house that the christ-killers fathers
[ __ ] senior rice pillow see
Joey did we get Presidents Day Off but
we don't get the day off when we vote
for president can you believe that [ __ ]
what kind of [ __ ] is in fact the
system's rigged the system was rigged
listen first of all anybody would knows
history knows we used to get to Monday's
off in a row we used to get the mundane
last Monday was Abe Lincoln birthday and
this Monday's George Washington's
birthday so years ago 20 years ago we
got that they took away Lincoln's
birthday and then they gave this Martin
Luther King which was smart that means
you got a
off on the 20th Maine Manor on the 20th
of January after Christmas lows you
don't say yeah yeah yeah yeah times you
go right from Christmas right to work so
at least they care about you so we lost
a day I don't know if you remember this
we used to get to know her off on a row
for years we got to Monday's off in a
row then they combined them to become
presence day so just a little history on
Presidents Day for you [ __ ]
nothin no dropping some knowledge always
on a Monday morning you gotta do
something with your [ __ ] self I gotta
we're gonna do a hit acid I brought some
[ __ ] acid back rolling around in a
park in North Hollywood Oh Benjamin
repeat I played in in Basel Switzerland
where LSD was invented are you serious
yeah and it's on that new head out in a
new album I mentioned this on that track
did you know what a magic day that must
have been so albert hofmann 1943 World
War two is raging and he was
experimenting with this [ __ ] and he he
he took a little accidentally and he was
riding his bicycle home when it hit him
and he just like rolled around in a
field for a couple hours laughing and
[ __ ] and then he went home the story of
like when the LSD was invented is
amazing so he goes home and when it was
in for this town
that's his welcome to Basel watch about
that but all these like pharmaceutical
corporations are based there so they're
making all kinds of [ __ ] they're like a
place to live Bassel switch on this is a
really nice place actually but like his
neighbor came over Albert Hoffman and he
thought he was like a witch or something
it's uh I haven't read the story in a
long time but it's it's pretty amazing
and I the first time I did acid was in
an apartment complex in Jacksonville
Florida with some people I didn't know
it was less enjoyable I was never I was
never a big acid fan I was against it
because the first time I did it it was
terrible and then for years I was never
you know a chemical guy but after my
sitcom and I had a ton of big pile of
cash I looked at that money as my NBC
artist grant and I moved to New York
City and I got a rock star apartment in
the Wall Street area and nobody lived
down in the Wall Street area at that
time and there was this acid head comic
from Baltimore
I'll save his name and he told me
because I know you're not into this but
I got some pure LSD dropped on two sugar
cubes I used to do here and he said he
goes I know you're not into this but
trust me I'm gonna give you ten of these
and I want you to try you just drop it
into a into a tea in a cup and then
drink the tea and then you know you'll
you'll be off so I would do I would do
like half of it at the beginning the
first like five I would only chop like
half of them up and do it and nobody
lived in the Wall Street area so I would
do this and I would put on I had
rollerblades and I would rollerblade
around the Wall Street area now it's
like you know fortress down there since
September 11th but used to be like one
taxi cab every few hours you know it was
nobody down there and you know it was
really fun - you didn't experiment what
acid yeah at a young age
no no no it's crazy cuz I watched I
watched the HBO Sports last week and I
wasn't aware this that the numbers the
football players it down what do you
mean football across the country is down
like the viewership no the people
getting kids get involved with football
eyes at ECE and they interviewed a lady
and mass and she put her son in when he
was six and can't do long - it had a
double double concussion hmm and then he
went back to play football at the age of
ten he hung himself [ __ ] and they took
the brain he had CTE already so that got
out so the numbers if you watch the
Super Bowl you saw that they have two
commercials and they're including girls
now in football it was really weird like
that I saw that and the next night I
watched this and where I'm getting at is
like I thought about my friends they
like
up with and a lot of them played you
know my high school was based on
football like new Jase a Texas yeah my
high school was based on football
everything ran around the football
program they took you when you were six
and they pretty much taught you to plays
you were gonna run in high school at
that age so you already knew them by the
time you played the Pee Wee's A & B you
know and I look at pick my friends put
all pictures up a football and I see
Jesus Christ like when I go home these
two guys have known themselves since
they was six like I hang out with people
that know themselves since they're six
sometimes I do shows and people come
together and they'll be talking about
peewee football my point is I called one
of my I spoke to one of my friends that
his father was a football coach and he
passed away I performed my mom we were
talking about football we compared it to
acid because those guys played football
and I said to out of all the friends we
had how many of them killed themselves
we thought about it i'ma leave this one
you know we also grew up in the 80s when
cocaine I mean we got right so we went
from doing acid and jumped right into
the cocaine boat but regardless of that
I remember selling acid so I was doing
it every night like I was doing MicroBot
acid every night for a run there after
my mother died that was how I got that
pain away it was by doing acid and I sit
back now and I think about if it gives
you PTSD or something like if acid
affected you like getting hit in the
head as a kid what do you think I did it
when I did it before I became a man and
my growth so I'm still waiting you know
when I was younger I was afraid of hard
drugs and then it wasn't until that
period 1998 1999 when I was living in
New York and then that's when I started
doing cocaine and then and I was
partying so much when I lived in New
York City I actually moved to Amsterdam
to bring it down a notch you know what
I'm saying because I was pretty
hell-bent you know Mitch Hedberg was one
of my best friends at that time he was
living at the Chelsea Hotel and you know
we were just
just partying like crazy and then I
started playing in Europe and I you know
met this Dutch woman and fell in love
and I moved there and and and it's it's
funny that it's true I actually moved to
Amsterdam to told it so I can tone it
down well my that's how hard I was party
I was the audience will New York has so
many different [ __ ] things available
to you yeah and it's hope I don't have
you know where can you get a haircut at
4:00 in the morning yeah in New York
City we were just talking about the
system which we thought we live here in
California and Lee eleven o'clock
sleepy drive factory town everything's
gonna live on Magnolia from here to
flappers at ten o'clock you could count
the people on one [ __ ] hand yeah if
that if you see somebody Burbank shuts
down at eight o'clock I've I've done a
hundred on Magnolia when I lost my
wallet as I was getting in a car I got I
got home over here when we lived up the
block I got my I got in front of house I
realized my wallet was gone I was
leaving the next morning I got in that
car into the hundred down Magnolia the
flappers I made the right to right where
I parked you could see the wallet right
in the street nobody didn't even it was
just sitting that there's no action at
all and then you go to New York and you
fall asleep at eight o'clock and you
wake up at midnight
in the world's available to you right
the world of it you know New York Maine
night at New York is nothing it really
is nothing you know you do a midnight
show somewhere it throws people off in
New York they go out at midnight
I went to two am comedy show yeah who do
[ __ ] girls want to see comedy at 2:00 in
the morning New York does well I was an
open mic it
I saw it though for there was a place it
didn't open mic go for geez and there
were a hundred people on the list
starting at what time 11:00 oh my god
and people be coming in getting hand
jobs you know New York as I walk but I
went back a couple years ago and I
stayed in the city and I couldn't sleep
it was one of those nights when I could
not fall asleep now for a walk it's not
like that normal it's calmed down a
little bit yeah that crazy lifestyle the
89 year
it's calm down those people get up and
go to work in the morning they go out
but they're home by 10 o'clock 10:30
they drink a beer with two two glasses
of wine and they go home it's not like
when I was growing up in New York at 3
in the morning once the bar closed what
do you want to do let's go into the city
and we would go into the city into the
shittiest part by a grandma blow go to a
[ __ ] bodega and they brown-bag the
beers and we just not coke on the street
and [ __ ] drink beers out of a brown
bag like nothing not even a cop would
stop I remember Dave Attell used to take
me to this bar it was called Siberia and
it was in the subway entrance I think it
it was a right off a Broadway like on
54th 50 seconds Waldo's [ __ ] Jesus
Christ this place was so it was like
standing room only and only like 8
people could fit in this bar it was like
it that you go down the subway steps and
like and then the first level and then
you get another step and then was just
like I don't know what the hell it used
to be and it's not there anymore
no but it was like seedy Russians in
there and you know it was always
narcotics available and you know it was
a really really crisp like
quintessential New York hole I can't
even get into like that was probably
four bars I went there before 1985 that
was just narcotic bars the one gay bar I
used to go to was just a drug place it
was just a drug and when you'd walk in
the door you'd see [ __ ] you never see
you know you pay a little extra to go in
for that
that's when club is we're still you know
ten bucks ticket in these places are
like 25 you're like ouch because you
could put your gram of coke on the table
and you nobody's gonna come and take it
nobody's gonna come to a line everybody
Minds their own business and it was
amazing to watch the [ __ ] eighties
and nineties in New York yeah and to see
how freely cocaine flowed how easily
people would just do lines on bar tops
yeah there was a bar in the Wall Street
area that was open all night
and there'd be these Wall Street guys in
there and they're doing coke and
drinking all night and then in their
suits and like they wouldn't even go
home they'd just like you know sit there
and sniff and drink until you know it's
time to go back in weaved a little
different it seems like I mean that the
dispensaries everywhere but it seems
like people mostly smoke at home and
then they'll go out hi but I don't
really occasionally you'll see someone
smoking on the street but not on the
street or on the corral you should go to
more comedy clubs in Los Angeles the
smell of weed is permeating everywhere I
guess yeah I'm just used to that that
seems normal to me now I work San Jose
this weekend no I've never been it's a
great club it's a theater great city
[ __ ] comedies forming that because
Gabriel sold 16,000 seats on Sunday you
know that whole area is comedy driven
like that whole area comedy comedies to
a new high I am [ __ ] really impressed
with comedy any club if this four
hundred club in the country three
hundred and sixty two of them are sold
out on Saturday nights no Meadows that's
the need for comedy right now in these
times that's how much people need to get
away the entertain and even that's what
all the entertainment value have it all
cuz you can watch [ __ ] murderers row
on Netflix you can watch a thousand
things on Netflix Hulu but that just
lets you know how many people are going
on on Saturday nights oh when I was in
Bray a couple weeks ago was it Brea yeah
all those clubs are sold out brea
ontario and they're getting down at it
shows in irvine you know it's like
comedies at an all-time high which tells
you people need to laugh more [ __ ] up
the world is there any that shows you
how [ __ ] up the world is right now you
know you can't watch the news anymore
the news is just the horrible you just
want to get into a bad mood
you sit there looking at this and you
know it's all [ __ ] they show you the
same [ __ ] report three days in a
[ __ ] row I avoid it I am you have to
watch some sort of news to see what's
going on in your community but if it
brings you down you like enough with
this [ __ ] already like I always try to
be home at 3:30 to watch World News
Tonight
I watched the first 15 minutes
and lately it's been cutting down for
the first 8 the first 7 the first 6
minute that's it it's the same [ __ ]
every [ __ ] day I read the news every
morning when I wake up what do you read
uh the Washington Post is my home page
and then I always look at the Guardian
okay which is it's kind of left laying
it leaning British newspaper which is
great and the BBC I really like the BBC
do you miss the newspaper coming to your
door yeah man I like there's nothing
like folding a newspaper and you know
getting pissed off and smacking it
against your leg and yeah and I still I
loved newspapers you know it's you know
New York Times Wall Street Journal Wall
Street Journal is a conservative paper
but it's one of the best written papers
there are great articles in there you
know they always said that if you read
the New York Times for four years you
would get more from reading the New York
Times every day for four years in the
college education you will learn more if
you read the New York Times now it's
like a [ __ ] you know piece of paper
somebody [ __ ] tickled your [ __ ]
thirty years ago that's all they live
for the New York Times just to wrap
people out now that's it that's it rap
people out they don't even care about
Trump none every week they rat some
wheels last week it was [ __ ] cake
Quigley's old boyfriend that [ __ ]
wizard who the magician Ryan whatever
his name is
Adams Ryan I had them see Ben Oh
sixteen-year-old girl the musician they
said magician yeah I love right yeah
it's like a wizard or something like
that real-life musical Wiz I love Ryan
Adams and I read that and I was like
[ __ ] no I don't feel the urge to listen
to his music yeah Mandy Moore's um he's
I can't iron through a rat them out Oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah oh no she oh yeah
that's a little more I'm always married
to him he wears a cape he makes you go
into a room naked and when we go for
this [ __ ] again that's why you got to be
a father to your daughters
[ __ ] magicians and [ __ ] [ __ ] go
into a dark cave you know he may take go
into a cave naked and she went for it
Jesus Christ Kate I could say your
[ __ ] bridge
somebody telling you ever wizard you
back I met a girl one night I was all
horned up in some [ __ ] town I think
it was now you meet these people on the
road and you can't believe it
when you walk out of a girl's apartment
that you want to [ __ ] and you know she's
your 3/4 there
what calmly is the only thing that like
you get to know who's gonna stroke you
from being on the road all those years
you just learn like he's just learned
that's it he's just learned he just know
how to read people and in some crazy
triple run I went home with some chick
and we were having a good time snorting
coke she was showing me her titties she
had the bikini on we were going deep
into the murky waters and then she
started talking about witchcraft and she
wanted me to look in her drawer she had
all these spells for love and the voodoo
man told that she was gonna meet me and
I'm like can I die for the car and get
something I took a rock coke I [ __ ]
never came back
I'm gonna snort coke get some [ __ ]
witch a white witch that's a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] trust one [ __ ] I swear to God
like I just walked out I took a rocket
coke if you didn't see me take it out of
the bag do that you're like eight
stories you have to leave you cannot
there's a point a conversation even when
you're doing coke right just get freaked
out yeah but say goodbye like yeah I
gotta go no no no you can't say goodbye
consume they're gonna give me a beat me
why you leaving but I scare you
I'm gonna put a spell on you I don't
want to hear now that you're having an
coke forever man those [ __ ]
conversing oh my god like alright we're
gonna get up at 7:00 and we're gonna go
kayaking everybody's like yeah that's
talking so much [ __ ] and then you get
then we're gonna go to my grandmother's
house and paint it yeah sure chopping
you dog I haven't been getting on planes
getting so coked up and having a
conversation and going
[ __ ] you let's go to Miami right now you
ever do that one I'm coach just get on
the plane
I even over the app well I have been on
I've been on airplanes on almost every
substance and the best way to fly
sober yeah I agree I mean all those no
the years ago when I was like partying
all night and you just goes all the air
for ice oh [ __ ] that's a word that's the
worst or even drinking on the plane like
I took a Viking on the plane about two
years ago horrible horrible [ __ ] idea
edibles on a plane on a six-hour flight
are not bad if the edible doesn't take
you to a certain level I think that's
different first-class than it is in
Congo it's the same everywhere you're in
coach you know and you eat an edible
your culture you get creeped out by the
first kid like when we flew the San Jose
the Indian woman of Indian women sat
next to the Agostini out of all the
[ __ ] rows she said she comes up to me
she did she was losing her hair she like
a [ __ ] bomb in it and he's asleep the
Agostino in the middle and I kept
reaching you make him believe I was
reaching I can't believe I was reaching
for it and I can see that was in the
middle just [ __ ] power we were
[ __ ] Alan if you fly with somebody I
suggest you take edibles like we took
out almost to New York yeah and get on a
plane you just can't get too [ __ ] up
like Ari said one time the doors locked
and he was ready to get off the plane I
mean if you would get arrested
come on animals edibles it just creeped
up on when they closed the door the
thing that you do that I don't like is
like I would get to his house at 4:00 in
the morning and we take the animal then
but then like that well the one time I
didn't like it was when we got on the on
the bus to the plane and since we took
the edible two hours ago I'm on a bus
standing like a family you go to Austin
Austin some of those cities out of LAX
American yeah you go to gate 50 if you
ever have like 55 a and B good night
that means you gotta go downstairs and
take that bus to a different Airport all
the way out in the middle of LAX and
they sell they have two stands in there
you'll get stuck in there it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
that's where you flow when you go until
I think it's two cities I've gone to
Oklahoma
and Austin you have to go out of gate
whatever and they put you on a bus we
just after you flown now you gotta get a
little bus to go back down you never did
that one that round
no I've stuck to with Delta for years I
saw it all and I yeah well I'm not happy
with them well with Delta either well I
so you know I'm getting divorced you
know that we haven't mentioned that
on this episode yet hey I'm getting
divorced everybody Greg yeah there's
nothing like the person who knows you
better than anyone else in the world
saying yeah I've had enough things I'll
get off at the next stop but one of the
reasons as you know that that's the
thing that kills every relationship for
a comedian is the constant travel so you
know I got this new album and it's
recorded in 25 different cities around
the world and this was a big project
I've been working on for two years and
so I've had all this international
travel two years in a row I have been
diamond level on Delta that's as high as
you can go so it's you have to fly a
hundred and twenty-five thousand miles
to reach diamonds which you know what it
is not easy to fly a hundred and
twenty-five that's that's sitting in the
[ __ ] seat a hundred and twenty five
thousand miles it is really hard I did
it two years in a row and it's it's nice
when you get to the Diamond level and as
a comedian who you know you work your
ass off it's it's nice to have that
little perk you know you get to board
with first-class you get to use the the
Sky Lounge when you fly so they changed
the rules last year for 2018 on top of
flying 125,000 miles you had to spend
$15,000 with the airline so last year I
flew one hundred and fifty five thousand
six hundred and nineteen miles on Delta
I want everywhere I did like four trips
to to to Europe I went to Israel I did
like two trips to Asia I flew to [ __ ]
monk
Lia and I spent $13,000 with the airline
so I was just downgraded to platinum hey
[ __ ] you Delta and I'm sitting there and
you got to watch the screen with it
Bastion the president of Delta Airlines
sitting there we really appreciate the
loyalty of our customers and all this
[ __ ] and it's like man it's difficult
you know I mean it I wouldn't say that
it you know it ended my marriage but you
know me traveling was a big factor in
the relationship ending and then I I
think Delta kind of [ __ ] me on on the
down grade I mean it's difficult to fly
a hundred and twenty five thousand miles
period and then you got to spend fifty
one that allows a mine dollar knowledge
when I look at flying I'm going in there
knowing I'm getting [ __ ] I play the
game I don't get stressed out about it
because there's nothing she could do
unless I'm gonna get in a horse and a
[ __ ] buggy yeah unless I'm gonna get
worse in a buggy and travel a drive to
New York and drive back it's the Mafia
there's nothing you could do I had a
friend that lived in Newark and will
come out here to train with Eddie Bravo
constantly and he said one day United
changed the rules on him and he had to
stop because he was getting upgrades and
this and that but then it's about the
money yeah they didn't do about miles no
more certain amount of [ __ ] of money
I'm like I fly with American all the
time am I crazy about him no no I'm not
but what are my choices when I get a
date the first thing I do is go to three
different screens you know I know but
from doing comedy for 20 years you know
who flies where you ready you already
know or you Travelocity and it tells you
direct flights or whatever and then you
go and attack a little American first I
go to Delta you're not it's my third if
I'm going east coast its JetBlue if I'm
going coast to coast I go JetBlue where
the Boston Florida or New York there's
no other airline I fly with throughout
the country it's basically about money
and time I'll pay extra if you get me
out of there five in the [ __ ] morning
I learned that from you take too early
friend Alex early felt light in early
fly it out and fly them so you don't get
caught in the rain of confusion look at
Thursday Thursday rained here like you
took the devil landed
you took the devil landed at one time so
they canceled my 11 o'clock and they
canceled the two of 12 o'clock the San
Jose thank God they got one every hour
on the [ __ ] now but here's the beauty
of it I knew I was gonna get canceled
you know why because my flight was at
12:00 on Thursday I didn't check in
Wednesday night till 10:00
you know what number I was - I was eight
- on Southwest business like us to help
grade you automatically I'm coming like
18 what everyone Southwest I love
Southwest by the way Southwest start in
June Burbank to Nashville like a
[ __ ]
oh that means I [ __ ] save thousands
by [ __ ] my wife and my daughter going
to Nashville am I correct direct Wow and
my wife there's enough to drive an hour
down with the baby that means the baby
doesn't get costs it we save on the car
sickness perfect perfect Burbank the
rank R it's beautiful banks are opening
up more [ __ ] routes you'll know how
hard that dick makes me I love it
line it out of Burbank is the way
they're going away I gotta find a new
place to live maybe I'll live over in
Burbank or Glendale or somewhere you
live now West Hollywood so I fly at LAX
one view and a but while it's still on
my mind you know what these airlines are
doing and Delta is spearheading it is
and like you're right it is all about
money now they're doing tiered economy
so there's different levels of the
economy for you know every anything you
have to pay for oh yeah you know they
get your window [ __ ] everything it's
like how [ __ ] greedy can these people
are you sit in the back with the [ __ ]
guys are getting transported for
murdering 12 kids and [ __ ] Texas
you're next to a guy that shackled they
put you in the back well didn't they
make billions off of baggage fees wasn't
that yeah and that was because the fuel
costs went up after September 11th and
then they said yeah
as a temporary measure we're gonna
charge for bags and then of course you
knew that it was never gonna go away but
that was just like a you know they're
laughing all the way to the bank or that
no it's a it's a scam it's it's ads you
know when I got on a plane when I look
at plane prices again I don't think
about me I think about the family or for
right I think about the family or for to
go anywhere jay-z's plane tickets are a
nickel apiece and that's base that's
base you know Messiah no less like right
now you flew into town and a good part
of the year from Florida like it's good
would you pay 340 yeah and that's a
[ __ ] sale of a lifetime no worries you
know it's like a yeah blue like a
[ __ ] it's I can kept saying when
I saw pre TSA I know it's not gonna stop
that it's not gonna stop there what do
you mean the pre check like that for all
the different how they got clear yeah so
now they're gonna keep going up and
everything cost they realize there's a
market for them you know if not you
gotta stand on line for two [ __ ]
hours if you don't get the Express check
through I don't want to wait after I did
six shows in the [ __ ] town and slept
five hours a night and talked to 3,000
people guess what Sunday I don't have
time to [ __ ] around I just want to get
through that [ __ ] Airport and get the
[ __ ] home that's all I'm thinking about
once they put a check in my hand on
Saturday night that's all I'm [ __ ]
thinking about but I've already there's
you got to pick your battles that's what
I'm about to say you got to pick your
battles when you travel and that's one
of the battles I've accepted I look at
the plane ticket look at the prices I
try to save a little bit my wife came to
me the other day and she goes I was
gonna take a flight to Nashville my wife
wanted to go back in June
the tickets are [ __ ] five hundred and
forty nine dollars base yeah it's all
going up you know what first class is to
Nashville next $1,900 well I get
upgraded to Nashville on American I
won't get upgraded to Chicago in New
York you learn all the scam yeah Canada
you'll never get upgraded that's silver
and platinum people ads Diamond people
you're dead
but Nashville Oklahoma on American I get
upgraded all those places I get upgraded
why I used to spread it around you know
and I used to always like try and get
the cheapest ticket and then about five
or six years ago I decided I'm only
gonna fly with Delta I'll pay the extra
50 extra 100 bucks 150 bucks just so I
can build up the miles and then get as
high as I can on the on the status thing
so that's why it's you know for years
I've been paying the extra money just so
I could be loyal to to Delta and you
know what did it get me
no it doesn't get you anything anymore
no once they went to the money thing I
knew it like I'm [ __ ] I only take you
know 18 19 flights a year I don't travel
my ass off like you do yeah and I look
at every flight when I got a call I look
at every flight first before I agree to
a gig make sure somebody's got an early
flight out of that so make sure some
[ __ ] got an early flight
yeah well I'm actually that's kind of
changed my whole I'm dialing the travel
back this year I'm only gonna do a
couple of international trips I'm gonna
focus on on LA it's like you know just
traveling constantly you know it's an
endless [ __ ] loop back to you the
divorce yeah I'm sure how long were you
willing for 10 years married for seven
yeah
I'm when I first met her with you and
she was very gung-ho about the comedy
yeah oh she loved it she used to go with
me - she's travel with me everywhere
she's to go to shows with me every night
pseudo manager yes sorts it helped me
with everyone in your house yeah the
producer the podcast yeah she edited it
exactly she ended up on a woman to be
married to a comic yeah if you survey
most comics they've been divorced since
they're you know I went through two
women in the beginning of my comedy
career that they could not handle the
lifestyle
- but when you love something the way we
love something they're always number two
yeah
they wrote for you to be successful at
comedy they have to be number two and
it's the tough yeah and that's it's
there I have put comedy above everything
in my life and I would have to say that
comedy is the love of my life is slow
because I would say yeah I made comedy
the priority over her over everything
I've ever done in my life and I mean I
don't regret it
I [ __ ] love comedy from 93 to 2006
Tommy had power over everything 2007
wasn't I started loosening up a little
bit I dated this poor girl I'm married
to for six years before I met her
parents why waste anybody's time let's
make sure I'm sick and tired of meeting
parents sick and tired of meeting
parents I did it the right way with this
one with Terry my wife now I did it the
right way because I had blown that
marriages the marriage was me starting
Tommy that's not getting along that was
a complete different story I had I
tormented my ex-wife in different ways
my wife just couldn't take the
day-to-day and the mouth type lifestyle
I was living with the drugs yeah I'm
talking about two relationships I had
one relationship but I really liked her
and she really liked me and we got a
wall she liked the comedy but then she
moved to New York I moved to New York
you know she was into going out and meet
her friends after work the happy hour
and I got an open mic it said yeah you
know I'm driving a limo to pay child
support to make ends meet and you want
to meet your friends to drink water and
giggle like I thought because that's
when friends was around so everybody
started hanging out like friends now six
in the group so she was just out of
Kansas and I saw what it did though they
can't they can't deal with it
you know like hell you were supposed to
be in a house wait on line no I mean
even when you live with even when you
live with a comedian it's a
long-distance relationship this way you
know and like we were talking about
before we
on air you know I got to be on the road
a couple weeks a month just to you know
pay the rent on your lights on but then
when I'm home
I'm doing sets at the Comedy Store and
The Improv every night so it's like you
know even when I'm home I'm not like a
liberal you know you know and you know
you can't really plan it how often do
you get gigs like for that night or the
next day or I have a life you do not
have a life from - from 93 to 2006 I did
not have a wife I didn't give a [ __ ]
about Christmas I didn't give a [ __ ]
about nothing that was the only mental
state you can have to get somewhere in
comedy 96 97 I didn't watch [ __ ]
television from 93 to 99 I didn't know
what a television show was cuz you what
kind of comic watches television if you
watch television you're not a comic yeah
if you're watching TV shows it's not
you're not really telling I don't know
what you're talking about you got to be
out of seven nights a week grind it I
didn't even know what a baseball game
long yeah I didn't give a [ __ ] about who
was in the Super Bowl nothing that's a
spicy these kind of nice to stay the
minors I'm young comics in LA and their
sets will be about like television shows
and did you see this reality show and I
have no idea I don't know what you're
talking about don't mind I go there I
don't even know what you're talking
about
you know there was a time when I was
just a [ __ ] monster and then I moved
here with a girl and she had a big
family and every [ __ ] two months they
thought like oh yeah we'll come out for
a week
that's great we planned the dinner I'm
not going that [ __ ] dinner cuz I got
a spot at 9:30 I'm trying to make a
living you know that was hard to live
with that's how tough and once a woman
realizes she's number two you're [ __ ]
done and then let's say you do get
married to this woman and you have a
child and now you really have to go on
the road how much time you're gonna be
home if you gotta go on the road three
weeks a month to keep the lights on you
got a kid so now you're calling your
wife and [ __ ] Mazatlan with Tom rose
go huh in the back going I'm in Mazatlan
we're having a great time I bumped into
the flying Jew and she's with a kid
crying your background how long does
that last
in the beginning it
daily comic he's so much fun oh my god
we'd giggle we walked through the coffee
store like Goodfellas we walk around
back oh my god so much fun he knows
everybody and give it a [ __ ] year
till you're sitting there by yourself on
New Year's Eve because we're in Boca
Raton yes I don't want to bring nobody
with me on the road yeah that was a
mistake I made with the first two that I
did not even go into it Terry that was
not an option
I took around one date the [ __ ]
what's that hellhole in Arizona was wait
Lake Allison I can have a suit were you
going to ward in the a chlamydia you
guys Camellia the [ __ ] Lake you get
foot foot fungus at [ __ ] Lake cabin
so it's the filthiest [ __ ] two people
you ever met in your life I took that at
one time on the gig because she was
gonna she wanted to drive I was on a
rent ecology without drive but that was
it I cut her off from going to gigs I
mean I think that's why my relationship
with my life my wife lasted so long was
because she did travel with me you know
she was a photographer and and and it
was great I you know we'd go to travel
in the world you know I used to when I
didn't live anywhere like three months
three four months a year I'd do in
Europe do a month in Asia a month in
Australia and she used to travel with me
everywhere when we first started getting
serious when we were dating I told her I
said if you want to be with me you got
to reduce your life to one checked bag
and to carry-ons
and she did it and it was great and then
a year ago she decided she didn't want
to travel anymore and then that was the
beginning of the end you miss her I do
yeah I love her and it was not my choice
at least you have no hatred in your
heart you look good I don't and there's
no bad feelings she doesn't have any bad
feelings it wasn't like some catastrophe
happened it was just like you know her
decision that things would be better if
we were apart so these are one of the
things in life this is part of being a
[ __ ] grown-up always it's interesting
ma'am that's it's great that you say
that because
Penny Marshall died I think in December
and I was reading her obey
qu arey I think it was in the New York
Times and there was a quote they quoted
the opening paragraph of her
autobiography and I don't remember it
exactly but it said something like this
her opening paragraph her autobiography
said I've been divorced twice I battled
cancer I had cancer and I had a child
commit suicide something like that and
she said nothing extraordinary has ever
happened to me in my life it's just
normal things that happen to a human
being so you're absolutely right like
divorce people you love dying just
things happen in life as you get older
that you just [ __ ] after weather and
move on you know somebody hit me up last
night and said are you having a hard day
over Ralphie May you know you're right
over there
obviously with Ralphie mades birthday Oh
most people would be crying and having a
bad day with I thought about it he
inspired me yesterday you know I just
thought about him for five minutes I go
what a [ __ ] shame in fact they gotta
call the smash brothers today because
I'm chipping in money to get him a
headstone nobody got the [ __ ] killer
head stop Wow I just found this out on
service Wow I was a nucleus I went
[ __ ] ballistic I called Aria so we're
gonna get ahead where is he buried he's
buried in Oklahoma and thank God for the
smash brothers a quarry in Chad I want
to thank them for bringing it to my
attention
you know meanwhile people are out
collecting money to make [ __ ] his
last video and selling his memorabilia
but nobody had the [ __ ] decency to
buy that [ __ ] kid headstone you know
well so that's what I was sick about
yesterday to be honest for everybody but
besides that what are we talking about
I'm sorry I have you were upset because
it was his birthday
yeah I wasn't really upset he inspired
me you know most Americans it's how you
look at things I could
Lika to call me and say what's up and I
could have yelled at Li and said don't
you know I'm having a [ __ ] bad day my
best friend died too you know this is
just a part of growing up this is just
part of up and every day you're a
fireman you ever see a fireman's hat I
have an imaginary fireman's hat on at
all times and so do guys like you and if
you plan on having a comedy or having
life in it and then and move along with
your life you have to have a fireman's
cap the fireman's cap is shaped the way
it is
so things hitting them bounce off and
they don't hey in the back have you seen
that low-cut in the back yeah and the
big flap on the bats what life is look
at your life go put them go look at
yourself in the mirror and put a
fireman's hat on and get ready get ready
be prepared [ __ ] does go down people do
get cancer people do die cats do die
you know kids are born without a [ __ ]
eyeball you know these are the things
and we all live and we we learn how to
live with them and we move the [ __ ] on
it's so weird you can you say get easier
the more happens you know I look at
these one of the greatest lessons I ever
learned one of the toughest things I
ever ever ever saw in my life that just
took me to the next level as a man was
an Eric Clapton's kid well I fell out
the [ __ ] window in New York yeah and
he went to some MTV Awards and dedicated
the song to him and sang it and kept it
together I'm not even I don't even know
[ __ ] Eric Clapton I can't keep it
together knowing that your little kid
fell out of a [ __ ] window in New York
he went out and wrote that if I saw oh
my god and he didn't shut it tear he
didn't break down they shook his hand he
hugged people and I'm like that's a
lesson that you know [ __ ] happens and
what does Eric Clapton gonna do go into
an apartment and write and do heroin no
he went and tackled that [ __ ] on
what's that [ __ ] white dude that
showed his dick to America everybody got
mad at him that wonder he won four or 15
super balls there for that [ __ ]
they told him and half time his father
died and he drew forth touchdown you
know I want that guy that's the
[ __ ] I wanna hang out with his
father died and he went that's what we
the best
his life look at his [ __ ] numbers
they told us that right before right
before the game we're sorry Italian your
father died they couldn't even wait that
[ __ ] white savage that he is you see
that guy you just suck his dick if I was
him I'd sent you pictures on my dick -
and you accept them you understand me
you don't say a word I do four
touchdowns in a day my father died on
Monday Night Football was son he passed
for 400 yards and four touchdowns
you said he showed his dick to America
he texted a worker for the Jets when he
was a kid he just sent pictures of his
dick I do 4,000 [ __ ] if I was Tom Brady
I had six rings everybody would see my
dick with a ring on it go ahead I make a
picture of my dick and show that the
Copernican whatever is [ __ ] famous
keep kneeling [ __ ] look at me I got six
rings on I guess it's like Jeff Bezos or
just man in the world showing his dick
do you imagine seventy billion dollars
he has to get payback now Bezos I'm
pretty sure isn't that the number
seventy million yeah yeah he's gotta buy
140 he's got to split it with us and
then it was the wives brother or the nor
the mistresses brother who scented the
text a song
that's a weird love for [ __ ] that's 70
million for a piece of [ __ ] that's
expensive
that means I'm killing that [ __ ] at one
point that means I could just dispose of
the body she belongs to be 70 million
dollars in appearance a billion billion
I'm gonna run to the little comedians
room okay go knock yourself out but this
is a [ __ ] like I got a choice you
know I'm saying that's what happens when
you're 50 that little bladder turns into
a little girlie bladder and [ __ ] and you
got a pee area on the [ __ ] hour
how its inner there this weekend San
Jose was tremendous I want to thank all
the people who came out to the show six
show sold out shows did they open the
top like the really cool part oh yeah
they opened everything everything that
had chairs out there [ __ ] San Jose
came out representing strong thank you
very much for a great weekend you know
Jenica Jones came they [ __ ] brought
tremendous banana bread with walnuts in
it
oh I love I hate him and passed out heat
I'm the only guy I could either an
edible wait to eat like I brought him
back to the room she made two of each
but she made some of these [ __ ]
walnuts on it and I was sitting there
watching the whole episode of [ __ ]
the Sopranos eating that [ __ ] with some
water at night it was tremendous yeah
we've been here and you've gotten the
munchies needing more edibles cuz you've
gotten the end I've got the munchies me
more about your situation is that
there's no children involved
there's no 70 billion houses for me
you're Jeff Bezos yeah for you well it's
funny you talking about splitting the
money in a divorce and I thought oh
that's a good time to step out no kids
no house oh that's good but that's it's
that's great that you asked me
point-blank do I miss her you know I
mean she was my best friend
so and now I don't have my best friend
so it's kind of [ __ ] up it's like a a
weird grieving period after because I
had the same thing lista she was my best
friend for six years or at least I tried
to make it that it was six bad years for
her you know she had to go to a prison
visit some bodies I put her through a
lot you know so I understand now at this
age what she went through and the reason
why you know she didn't want to go into
the future with me you know they can't
count on us yeah you know one thing when
I started dating the wife I have now is
I did different things differently you
know and if I told I'm gonna do
something I do it you know you got to
work at marriage this man I mean your
atomic you know I've been here for 20
years I've heard all about the divorce
there's no the thing I dread the most is
these guys that after 35 years of
married they got divorced Jesus Christ
if I divorce my wife now I could
function
yeah well I mean that's the that's it
did the tough thing 20 years with my
wife now
yeah I couldn't function my life is
everything well my wife did everything
for me she helped me with social media
and she helped me with [ __ ]
everything I do my own work but my wife
doesn't everything else like everything
is prepared for me everything is fine
you know she knows I'm trying to eat
better she cooks a little better I'm my
wife you know now that she's a mom she's
really you know the role but I work hard
at it
you know this temptations I have not
sexually or nothing workwise things I
like to do that I have to think about us
as a family
yeah and go I'm already gone six days a
week how can I go to my wife and tell
her I wanna go to Vegas to watch this
well you know so I work at things like
that
do you know Miami yeah I know you and
you you know you always you're very
protective of your time with your family
you have to really express what I wasn't
I didn't have a family
yeah but like what you were talking
about before about like working holidays
and [ __ ] like that which is I did a lot
we could we had a lot of things weavings
yes I would go work in Vancouver because
it ain't Thanksgiving up there and it's
boom Mike there's another cheque I can
this is but I in from where I'm sitting
I think as a comedian you can't let too
many big days or holidays slip by
without you being there and then sitting
by themselves in your Los Angeles
apartment that's you know even though
they say yeah go get that money yeah
that's fine
yes because I asked her permission for
everything you know hey you mind if I go
to Vancouver and work for Thanksgiving
and then you know it's it sounds great
until it happens is she working now and
stuff no she's still not working no you
know it's weird I I [ __ ] up so many
relationships two of them that I really
liked and a lot of valuables were
involved don't just blame it on the copy
there was the coke and the [ __ ] yeah
this time I wanted to do it right and I
try to do it as right as I can to the
tea you know we're all flesh is weak we
make mistakes but I really tried to
I live in an empty house I know and you
know there's a lion at the at the end
the dogs by Pink Floyd it's a brilliant
line you know who wouldn't walk brought
up in a house full of pain who was
taught not to spit in the fan who was
told what to do by the man you know like
something about coming home to an empty
house even though this family in the
house I know what that feels like I had
it in my house before my parents split
and I had it what before I got divorced
there's a feeling in your house and that
feeling I never want that feeling again
so once I had mercy but to be honest to
you I I started trying to do better when
I was dating her that's when I stopped
with the sundaes on the road little
things to have a family you have to eat
dinner with the family on Sunday it's
the Lord's Day when I was growing up
that's all I ever wanted and all my
white friends did it and on Sundays at
my house it was what's called room by
you you know to buy you is [ __ ]
people all over the house watching
baseball drinking beers I didn't like
that I believe Miss Sunday is your
family after you eat dinner you watch
the Wild Kingdom and then Disney member
yeah the clock was on before that we
were grown up the animal kingdom with
that dude the husky dude with the
[ __ ] voice so Sundays at 6:00 she ate
seven would come on guys walking
somebody I remember I write then at 8
o'clock was the wonderful world of
Disney on NBC yeah that was that was
what America was built on and lost in
those valleys or not the window they
started putting football on at nine
o'clock to 8 o'clock and that chubby guy
that played with Tigers and [ __ ] that
was what America was about we forgot all
about that we threw that away I
understand the need for Americans to
work on a Sunday
I worked plenty of [ __ ] Sundays
around was single and there's people
that have families that still have to
work on Sundays to support those
families but for me to make it work with
her
to make her feel normal I had to be home
on Sundays so at least no matter what
happened throughout the week Sunday's we
stand each other need family as a dental
hey dinner as a family that's big in my
world so that was when I first cut out
and it drove people crazy drove Rogan
crazy it drove everybody crazy comedy
clubs with Tommy I couldn't work there
if I couldn't work Sunday fine fine I
just will not I made those little cuts
for my wife I looked at other comics
that were successful and I would see it
there all of a sudden they would start
to get divorces and get separated that's
the [ __ ] reason why a woman gets
married for one thing security not that
we have to support them no woman is
looking for some guy to support them
even though there's some dirty [ __ ]
out there every woman wants to hold her
own but at the same time our schedules
are so [ __ ] you know well Horace well
Horace I can look in the face and go I'm
in the whole month of March and then
March 17th bumpty in Dallas and the
connecting flight and you go I thought
you were home bro
that was called this club yea in this
club low horse I had to stop being a
[ __ ] I had to stop being home I'm
becoming a comedian you know but that's
for me that's what makes it work for me
you've always been a nomad since I've
known you you've always been a nomad
that's why when you first came to me and
said you would get married I looked at
you said to you get married you're
[ __ ] nomad you were going on you
going to Europe when nobody else is
going here yeah you've been doing this
[ __ ] for twenty years in fact I heard
Golden Earring today Twilight Zone I
thought about your show and I'm and you
had on the show I was never by Harry Hay
you are always doing the Europe thing
when these [ __ ] idiots was still
doing improv so you've always been a
nomad that's why when you said you were
married I wished you luck but you're a
[ __ ] Savage you're the last of the
[ __ ] savages from the eighties
there's nobody else doing what you're
doing anymore well if she had asked you
to only do a mare
and do Thursday through Saturday like
what you've been happy living like that
well you know it's funny like now after
the nuclear fallout of the breakup I
think oh okay I'll give that a try but
no I was too hardheaded
to give it up and then also I was driven
by this project of this this album but
you enjoyed traveling and you said
you're cutting a down next year but
you're still doing in a Europe tour an
Asia tour you enjoy traveling so that
you wouldn't want to give it up probably
I like it I like having I like having
comedy friends all over the world
comedian friends I like knowing you know
comedians in every country or great
friends of mine and I like this skill
and intelligence that it takes to be
able to crush in different countries
like you're in Ireland one week and then
you're in England the next week it's
it's different the audience is then you
go to France or Holland or you know
Japan or Mongolia it's I mean it's
different like Chicago is different from
Atlanta and San Francisco is different
than you know Phoenix you know it's it's
an adrenaline rush that I get off on to
be able to go to these different places
and then also like the the new album I
really worked my ass off on like there's
a lot of you know it's it's I recorded
it in 25 different cities around the
world it comes out this this Aires yeah
so it comes out when you're hearing this
Laurie 19 yeah the album is out now it's
called around the world starts in Paris
ends in Jerusalem so you know there's a
lot of cities like Paris and Amsterdam
that I have long history with that I've
got stories about and and great jokes
about because I've been doing the
International circuits for for twenty
years but then there was other places I
went like Berlin and Oslo and Stockholm
and Israel where like I made it these
writing projects to write a hunk of
material you know at least five minutes
of new material on that place that I was
going to so in the last two years making
this album I really
you know I'm just just reading books
about the [ __ ] that interests me most
about these different countries and then
googling interesting facts and I think
this album is the best thing I've ever
done
let me ask you this when you it's called
around the world and I see 40 tracks
here now are they gonna be 40 tracks on
the album that's the eighth day that's
the tracks of the album and Paris one is
lasting how many minutes I think it's
it's like four minutes maybe three and a
half day okay yeah you were giving us
the whole show no no no no no okay this
is the album is don't even know what
half of these places are there's like a
sofa me out the outlet oh I don't even
know a port I don't Portugal that's him
okay yes Gretel you played portal
he had like pornos of Burbank in
Glendale and I about the album is three
hours long where's Galway Ireland
Belfast Ireland London Berlin Berlin
Zuri
check him too [ __ ] Nazi information
Stockholm Vancouver Sydney Bangkok
almost drowning in Thailand you almost
drowned in Thailand yeah you never heard
that story
no yeah almost drowned in [ __ ]
plainly I 2004 I had a when I was doing
the after the late-night talk show in
Amsterdam the same Network let me be a
presenter on a travel show
so I got to do a highlight on st.
Petersburg Russia on Perot the Champagne
region of France and doing here the
story yeah I mean it's on the album the
so I was doing I was doing the stand-up
comedy tour in Asia I did Hong Kong and
Bangkok and I had two weeks off before I
had to go to Tokyo so my Dutch travel
show boss said that if I got certified
diving while I was in Thailand on my
next assignment he would send me to the
Dutch Caribbean and then we could film
some underwater [ __ ] in the Caribbean so
I flew from Bangkok to Phuket and I took
a boat for three hours to the pp Islands
and I went to koh pipi and i
this French resort and my diving
instructor was this tattooed criminal
scumbag from Montpellier France named
Philippe and you could smell the cocaine
criminal past on this [ __ ] guy I mean
there was a reason why he was hiding out
in the islands in Thailand yeah and all
these homemade jailhouse tattoos on his
arm
yeah little rat ponytail and he had a
mustard yellow speedo that matched his
mustard yellow teeth and anybody who's
ever gone diving you have to study a
book for like a week before you're ever
allowed to get into the water I did not
have to look at this book for one second
i sat with a very hungover Philippe on
the morning of my first dive and he went
through the hand signals with me this
means I cannot breathe this means I have
a love of air a love of air okay I'm
underwater oxygens precious okay love
here took me three days to figure out
that this means you are low of air so my
diving class was very small it was a
British couple from London mark and Mara
and I'm still very good friends with
them because of what happens in this
story and my diving buddy when you go
diving you're matched with a buddy for
safety you have to constantly be
checking on your buddy are you okay
buddy I'm okay buddy
so ziplining yeah so I was supply III I
had been dumped by the the Dutch woman
that I moved to Amsterdam for it's a
recurring theme in my life I've been
left more times than pizza crusts so
anyway so I was I was freshly single and
heartbroken at the time and my diving
buddy was this beautiful French woman
from Bordeaux France named Helene and
Helene worked at the ticket counter for
Air France at Bordeaux International
Airport and I fell instantly in love
with her how perfect we met while diving
in Thailand I'm imagining my future life
living in Bordeaux I'd get a job
smashing grapes with my feet I pick her
up at the end of the day at Bordeaux
International Airport we
are shaggy dogs out to the coast and
tennis balls for the dogs to chase and
make love in the sand dunes at the
sunset well
Helene spelled the minimal English and I
speak minimal French and Philippe also
had a crush on this woman so his
underwater flirting was outrageous every
day he'd pushed me aside and take her
and show her pretty plankton and
whatever and I'm by myself above the
blub so a lot of men do this when
there's a rival for their affection he
becomes the silverback gorilla and he
feels the need to loudly insult me in
front of the group every chance that he
gets so we all said what we did for a
living I said I worked on this
television show so he keeps calling me
mr. television is this good enough for
you mr. television you must learn Zippo
and see mr. television you will not get
your diving certificate until you learn
zip buoyancy buoyancy is the perfect
balance of perfect measures when you go
diving of an air vest and there's two
buttons one increases the air the other
one decreases the air professional
divers in the tanks on your vest of
investment professional divers are
always perfectly horizontal they never
use their hands except for this really
cool II just go shh-shh
while amateurs flare their arms and
that's what I keep doing and it keeps
yelling at me over the buoyancy so every
day we would have lunch on these
beautiful islands on these little alcove
beaches and one day Helene was pulling
her bikini bottom out of her ass crack
and I asked mark to ask her if she was
going to the movies she says why I say
because I saw you picking your seat
it's a children's joke in the United
States she had never heard it before she
thinks it's the funniest joke ever she's
bent over laughing ah and I look at
Philippe and he's [ __ ] I daggers at
me man he's so pissed off that I scored
a point with this woman so on the
morning that I almost died he was being
a real dick to me and we're in the boat
and we're driving out to our diving spot
and he's yelling at me over some stupid
[ __ ] and I I said hey Philippe
I don't know what I did to make you
dislike me brother
but I gotta be honest with you men
you're making me feel uncomfortable and
I have to trust you down there and he
goes oh mr. American have I hurt your
feelings
maybe Zee al Qaeda has asked me to leave
your body in the ocean today and that's
what Mark stands up in the boat and goes
you out of order and then they got into
each other's faces and then they almost
fought and it was like an hour before
this explosive situation finally died
down and we all got to go diving and in
retrospect it was Russian roulette with
the bad tank and I got the bad one did
he give it to me on purpose we will
never know because when we were dying
when we're driving out to the spot it
was announced that one person couldn't
go diving because one of the tanks was
bad and then the tie boat captain like
hit it with a shoe or something while
this argument was going on and then was
decided we could all go diving so just
like every other day we get down there
he pushes me aside he takes her he's
showing her [ __ ] I'm by myself boo boo
boo blub and then I start breathing in
water and your lungs don't want water
it's day three I know how to work the
equipment there's a button in front of
your mouth if you get water in your
mouth you hit the button and she shoots
out the side it's not working I get my
spare respirator the octopus as they
call it it's the same thing it's water
your lungs I want water and I look up
and it's like 4050 feet it's not that
deep but it's deep enough to be
dangerous and I know you can never shoot
straight up to the top and diving that's
how people get really injured so I look
at Philippe and I don't know he's like
20 30 feet from me and I swam to this
[ __ ] guy as quick as I could and I
actually came in a little above him and
I had to whip him around by his ponytail
to get his attention and who would have
thought I ever would have gotten to use
the I cannot breathe signal and he
really seemed to take his slow sweet
time getting me that spare respirator
and by the time I got to my mouth I had
held my breath for so long I can't even
recreate the sound that came out of me
it was the sound of someone dying and it
came out of me and I'm just taken in all
this water and I'm gasping on this
[ __ ] thing but I can feel him moving
me upwards and I
survived barely got to the [ __ ] I
never thought we'd reach the surface I'm
Jai and I actually thought this is the
last moment of my life watching bubbles
go in front of this French [ __ ] face
but I survived
and I had to wait on the boat while
everyone else finished their dive and
I'm sitting there and the tide boat
captain was fishing and he caught a fish
and he pulled it up onto the boat and
the fish was flopping around and I felt
so bad for that fish because that was me
just a minute ago and then so we go back
to the island and I sat on the beach and
I watched the sunset and to be honest
with you it was a very mediocre sunset I
was really hazy and overcast that day
but it was the greatest sunset I've ever
seen in my life there's nothing like
almost dying to make you really
appreciate living so then Philippe walks
up and then he invited me into the
little village to have a beer and I know
he was trying to cover his ass but you
know he made an effort he showed me a
picture of the wife and child he had
abandoned in France and I told him I
said Philippe I want you to know today I
learned the true meaning of buoyancy
because this morning when you said that
[ __ ] about al-qaeda I hated your guts
and I wanted you to die and then you
saved my life and then all is forgiven
that's the perfect balance of perfect
measures then I go back to the resort
and Helene was sitting at the tiki bar
by herself so I went over and I tried to
make small talk with her and I go so
what's the first thing you're gonna do
when you get back to Bordeaux and she
goes make love to my boyfriend hey so
what's the second thing you're gonna do
second thing so be careful who you
almost die for cuz they might not give
him a fart they don't you know goes
scuba diving any time Joey and now you
know I almost drowned in peeping yes my
biggest fear is drowning right yeah I
won't drown when I was six at Coney
Island mmm and it was a [ __ ] scary
thing I never swam again for about a
year and a half yeah I I actually went
back the next day and I knew if I didn't
go back the next day of the field I
would never do it again in my life and I
had to go back one more day to get
certified diving so
like my little class all got their
certificate and then the next day was
these professional divers who wanted to
go look at sharks in caves [ __ ] last
thing in the world I wanted to do so
these lunatics
should we go down to some different area
where there was these sleeping sharks in
caves and they're all sticking their
heads in it and [ __ ] and I'm just like
you know I I just want to get certified
so I got over it all you know so so I
ended up getting certified and then I I
got to go to her a sow and Aruba and
then we filmed it was actually on my
birthday but the I got to swim through a
shipwreck off the coast of Korea Sal and
we had underwater cameras and they
filmed me swimming through this fish
this shipwreck it was pretty [ __ ]
cool you had an interesting life
I've had an interesting life yeah it all
brought to you by comedy everything's
been the catalyst every day comedies
brought me everything how many years now
you don't know thank you for asking
February 4th 35 years started when I was
17 and I just turned 52 so 30 regrets if
you had to do it over again ah you know
I mean you know just uh the the is only
if there's only two things I regret in
my life I wish I would have done some
things differently with my wife
obviously you know I miss her still love
her and you know I don't know if I'll
ever get that close to someone ever
again but the only other thing I regret
is I opened for James Brown in 1996
he's one of my all-time heroes in life
and I still play the [ __ ] out of James
Brown constantly and I had the chance to
go backstage and meet him after the
concert and I didn't meet him because
you know when you're young and you're
idealistic and you think all kinds of
stupid crazy [ __ ] I thought I wanted to
preserve my image of the young virile
James Brown that I had it but I just
watched his concert and he was in his
60s he was still great it was complete a
lime green jumpsuit on and he was still
doing splits and [ __ ] and
but I didn't want to meet him because I
didn't want to tamper with I've met so
many heroes that disappointed me
and I didn't want to that's how sacred
James Brown is and was to me I didn't
want to tamper with my image of how did
they disappoint you and which way I mean
just like you know being arrogant or
blowing you off like a member being
younger meeting famous comedians and you
know all they cared about after the show
was you know meeting some young women
and get away from me kid
it's really disappointing takes like a
day or two at least for me to so I
didn't want to take the chance of Jane
Brown like ask me maybe I'd go backstage
and you know he's in his underwear some
old man he's got his wig on a hanger and
you know accidentally see through his
pee hole and see some weird old guy
shriveled up dick you know I don't know
I it was stupid but you know it's just a
weird [ __ ] you think when you're a kid
like no man he means so much to me I
just you know it was just an honor to
open for him and it was yeah I will have
that forever Robert yeah you'd have been
open for Ray Charles once too in 1998
but but it's stupid that's though that's
probably one of the only ruts that I
have is that I wish I'd have met James
Brown when I had the chicken ship
sometime you know I think about all the
way back to the 8th grade
oh I dumped that poor girl cuz her
mother died some girl I was dating Jesus
I was dating Oh like I didn't know she
played basketball she was a cheerleader
I liked it boy the kids you know we meet
for pizza we'd double-date another
basketball player it wasn't even like
sexual I'd suck her titties behind the
church that type of [ __ ] and one day
finally so that's why churches were
built oh my god does that come over the
[ __ ] house and I went over there and
she's like what time does she dad tell
him she's like five people what time's
your mom get home because my mom died I
just freaked
I just [ __ ] freaked I was like you
know I didn't freak in front of her I
just kind of shocked inside and I'm the
bus ride Conal what do you have to do
for your mom to die like what the [ __ ]
did you do I couldn't even fathom it
when I started dating another girl and I
broke up with him
and when my mom died and I found that
that's the first person I thought of you
know and she's on Facebook now and I was
like reaching out and saying hello but I
don't have the R - that's interesting
man I had that you know my my father
died in 2009 and then my little sister
died in 2011 and then my uncle died last
year and it hit me I had this epiphany
last year after my uncle died that's why
young people are all so happy because
everybody they love is still alive you
haven't let you know had people snatched
from you I mean you didn't know how to
[ __ ] deal with it you're young you
know you know the concept of death even
as an old person everybody's afraid of
it cuz nobody knows what it is you know
are you gonna deal with the concept you
can't even comprehend when you're young
the funny thing is the kid that made me
when I was a kid the kid who put me in a
better position died when he eighth
grade I was playing basketball with him
until about 6:30 - his mother called him
for dinner he asked me you're coming
over I go na Mele go home tonight
I went home he went home and the next
day in the eighth grade when I went to
school they said he got into a car
accident with his brother and he was
gonna calm and stuff like that you were
supposed to be in that car no not at all
no it's funny that I still think about
him it's weird that now looking back we
didn't know how to how to react to his
death in the eighth grade
yeah but looking back once after that
you could see our behavior changed like
looking back I've been writing about it
lately how we move from smoking pot to
once a week every day now and awesome
we're adding alcohol to the mix and then
we uh after you died we just liked on
our own went from one level to the other
and then another kid from the
neighborhood died sophomore year round
and that neighborhood never recovered
like I still see some of those kids and
their name
they never recovered me one one of them
being me nobody knew how to really
handle that in eighth grade and even
writing about it last week a couple
weeks ago I didn't I remember going to
the hospital and seeing him on the
ventilator because he went into a coma
first he was in a coma first when they
pulled him off the ventilator and he
died and him and I were like early
stoners and we listened to kiss all the
time and at that time I think I had to
kiss out that we used to trade kiss
alive me and him would trade it and I at
the [ __ ] funeral I buried him went to
kiss albums I put him in his casket and
I said I'll never listen to kiss without
you next time I'll see it wasn't a kiss
and I never really listened to kiss
recently I started a little bit but
never at all Wow sorry I didn't know it
affected me then now I know how much
those two that's affected me and then
throw my mother in between the both of
them so it was Anthony first my mother
then Dominic Dominic died maybe 10
months later my mother died in November
Dominic died August 4th that destroyed
the neighborhood and I still talked
maybe three four or five people in their
neighborhood god I mean how come but you
know it's the the concept of death is
completely removed from our society we
don't even see how our food is killed I
mean how are we supposed to know it's
[ __ ] knowing what we ever talked about
we don't want to know until you've
killed yeah true but don't want to know
you know just death in general it's like
you know people don't talk about it
until it hits you you know and you know
I was destroyed after my father and my
sister died oh no I stopped drinking for
pleasure for two years you stole off the
booth still off the booze yeah [ __ ] god
bless you amen
January versus five years yeah no desire
known even after this a people called me
you know and you are one of the few
friends that reached out to me several
times since since my breakup and I
really appreciate that and you asked me
all other people that called me you know
you're not drinking on you know just you
know and that really means the world to
me have no idea but I have no [ __ ]
desire whatsoever and I was actually in
I was feeling at my [ __ ] lowest and I
was in Hollywood and I was walking I had
to go to the bathroom and I was was
right by the Pantages Theatre and the
frolic room is next door and I've been
in the men my bomb my brains have been
splattered all over the frolic rooms I
mean I was still there yeah and you know
it'll be there after we're dead they
changed everything in that neighborhood
yeah but that's still like the same
gritty Hollywood bar that it always was
so I mean I popped in there and like the
a thousand ghosts of Tom Rhodes past are
in that bar and times I was in there and
had a great time all kinds of different
stages in my life and just getting
plastered and you know and that smell of
the [ __ ] stale beer on the carpet and
you know I had no desire whatsoever I
just you know hey I'm here to take a pee
and get the [ __ ] out good for you yeah
man it's a you know I'm I I want to go
you know I may never go back to drinking
and I'll never go back to the way I used
to be but I want to go at least ten
years like when I'm in Paris like all
the parents of my favorite city in the
world and I got so many stories about it
and yeah or like me you're in Rome it's
like you know a glass of wine would be
nice I mean maybe it won't be as nice as
I think it'll be but I want to go at
least 10 years and then and then maybe
I'll have a glass of wine he's no
smoking reefer yes yeah III had to take
a break in January because it was
[ __ ] depressing me even worse you
know I spent here here's a great story
for you I try I've tried to turn this
into I've been saying this on stage but
I think it's a little too raw and
painful for it to be funny but I spent
January alone in my apartment crying and
that's what happens when you get
divorced and and it was pretty
ruff you know and I've been focused on
on this album and I'm writing a book to
go along with it so it's great to put my
energy into that but the truth of the
matter is and that's why you know
getting a call from from from you meant
the world to me you had no idea you know
what my situation was and I appreciate
you I know you I appreciate you
that you were concerned about you have
to listen [ __ ] means the world where
the Marines of copy yeah and there's
just a couple of us that really you know
I live my life by one rule like sunny
and Bronx Tale nobody Candice these
people tell you save the whales and yet
it's all for attention nobody really
cares you know nobody they see you at
the Comedy Store they blow smoke up your
ass and yeah at the end of the week
nobody [ __ ] cares in this life and
I've been very lucky I've had people
were checked up on me and say hey what's
going on for me divorce is one of the
hardest things I have a little I'll
never go through it again I don't ever
want them that's how I feel Eliz it is
one of the most rotten feelings in the
world especially as time goes you have
not even began your grieving process you
know yet you know in time you'll meet
somebody else and things will move on
but a divorce stings you a little bit
because at first you go through emotions
you go through a ton of emotions but at
this point in my life you know close to
25 26 after my divorce I put it down
with my GED with me quit in high school
I failed that one of the most simplest
things in life friendship you know I
failed that being a friend that's what
you are when you're a husband or a wife
yeah you're an extended friend you know
you don't want a girl when I was 21 I
made a decision don't when a woman told
me she cheated on me I was done because
the first time you tell me you love me
love doesn't disrespect as Biggie Smalls
put it in 1995 love never
never never never never everything else
you know Wayne this is yeah let them say
what the [ __ ] they want but love never
disrespects you know and now it's just
weird I knew you were going through why
we'll never I think you won the [ __ ]
best comics work the last set I saw you
doing the original room when you brought
me up about seven eight weeks ago and
sometime mid-december because you were
still married yeah and you called me I
didn't want a couple days later I said
I've been thinking about your set it was
one of the most brilliant things I've
seen and stand-up and it's so weird how
comics get hot and they create this
scene for themselves and you're not
really looking at
I feel Tom Rhodes you're one of the best
comics working today and I look in the
eye theaters when no bull shall need the
most look up your ass so yes when I
found that you would get divorce it
concern me
you one of the best guys representing
what we do out there you write you call
backs you you [ __ ] sacrifice the
marriage for comedy for this album
that's right in front of you so every
face I would like [ __ ]
comedians yeah I don't care if you're a
woman of you're a man I respect the work
that ethic that goes behind being a
comic I respect it with all my heart at
27 years and who's faking the funk yeah
I'm with him it I respected more than
anything in the world and I always say
the comedy is my religion and my
political party that's all that I
[ __ ] care about my first so to have
your respect means the world to me but
beyond that the fact that you were
concerned about me and you called me
several times to make sure I was doing
okay I will never forget that you've
always we've always been a great friend
to me but like I'm serious that I will
never forget that as long as I live that
is part of what goes with commie that's
a part of those with life that we only
have a couple handful of friends and we
gotta check up on them and check in time
to time I love you joy Diaz I love you
too
right what's the name of this
so the album's in hold around the world
but let me tell you this this story that
it showed you how [ __ ] up what I've
been going through so I spent January
alone crying in my apartment so like
this old friend of mine this girl I've
known her since middle school
and a great friend man and then she's
been dating this guy for years and then
there they got married two weekends ago
so she asked me to officiate you know
whatever I mean I'm happy to do it
you know and I got ordained online a
couple of clicks and I read a hafiz poem
that I thought was fitting and and and I
gave them what they wanted but my heart
was you know it was it was painful being
there around all this happiness and all
these love songs and here's these people
starting a marriage and mine has just
ended so it was great I was happy to do
these friends a favor but to be honest
with you I couldn't wait to get the [ __ ]
out of there so I call a lift and I get
in the lift and the lyft driver goes hey
that looks like a nice party you're at
oh yeah well it was a friend of Mines
wedding and to be honest with you I
couldn't wait to get out of there
because I'm going through a divorce
right now and I spent January alone in
my apartment crying and the guy said I
can relate to you getting divorced my
cat just died so I came home and I found
my cat and I just picked it up and I was
holding it I was crying holding my dead
cat and I said at least you got to hold
something it's like it's too raw and
it's too [ __ ] up to be funny yet Tom
rode dewdrops tonight yeah man my album
is out now it's called around the world
and look at those tracks it's right in
front of you man it's it's it's it's a
masterpiece
I have to say the album is three hours
long Kong Shanghai starts in Harris ends
in Jerusalem and it with the Jews I love
it that's the way they do it yeah man I
did it with the Jews I did this tour in
Israel in December and I took my 80 year
old Jesus Freak mother with me to to
Jerusalem and we flew in a week early
and
is pretty amazing yeah doing your story
are we not we're rep or wrapping up okay
yeah no problem
hey everybody buy my album around the
world it's the best thing I've ever done
and I'm rode the map you made time to
come on today
why is mentor you miss you look
completely different than when you
walked in here yeah he took a load off
your [ __ ] shoulders now on your face
and this is what these are a body date
you want to promote yeah next month I
met sides butters in Tampa I'm at comedy
off Broadway in Lexington great club
great room I love that great club yeah
and then I met the punch line in San
Francisco the great weekend of March
good yeah you buy my album come see me
live I will be at Treasure Island this
Friday night would Kate Quigley and at
the Fox Theatre in Tucson on Saturday
night with quake Kate Quigley and then I
think I got March 2nd at the Ice House
that's it I got a like couple we Savin
our uncle Joey all right I want to thank
Tom Rhodes I want to thank the flying
Jew over here and I want to thank you
guys most importantly but I also want to
tell you something for a second there I
want to talk to you about Robin Hood
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
kryptos or Commission free well other
brokerage charges up to $10 for every
trade Robin Hood doesn't charge any
Commission fees you understand me no
Commission feeds so you can trade stocks
and keep all your profits plus there's
no account minimum deposit needed to get
started so you can start investing at
any level Robin Hood the simple
intuitive design of Robin Hood nation
investing easy for newcomers and experts
alike view easy to understand charts and
market data and a place a trained and
just for taps on your smart phone
that's for tax and you could place your
trade you can also view stock
collections such as 100 most popular
with Robin Hood you can learn how to
invest in a market as you build your
portfolio discover new stocks track your
favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price movements so you
can never miss the right moment
to invest my wife loves this do you
understand me so what I'm doing is this
Robin Hood is given the listeners the
family of the Church of what's happening
now a free stock like Apple for the
sprint to help you build your portfolio
just to get started so do me a favor
sign up at church dot Robin Hood calm
that's church that Robin Hood calm I
want to thank also on it for being the
best when it comes to supplements
kettlebells club bells all that stuff
that can help you with this supplements
all right whether it's a shrimp export
the shrimp tech immune the alpha brain
the protein part of the beef jerk either
help whatever that is I get your ten
percent off go when you check out go to
the box and press in church BAM and get
ten percent off the living right to your
[ __ ] la casa
I'll see you [ __ ] bright and
early Thursday stay black kick this
[ __ ] meal week